While we hope that you have a seamless
RStudio Cloud experience,
occasionally things
might not work as intended.
Sometimes when we're working on a project,
it may fail to load
or become unresponsive. When this happens
we can relaunch the project by clicking on
the three dots inside a circle
to the left of the settings
icon at the top of our project.
Choosing the third option from this menu
will relaunch our project.
If this doesn't solve your issue,
you can check to see
if there are any broader issues
with RStudio Cloud.
To do this, expand the menu on the left
to expose the current system
status option in the help menu.
Clicking this will tell us if RStudio
Cloud is running as intended.
If RStudio Cloud is operational
and you are still running into issues,
you may choose to post on our community
forum or reach out to our RStudio
Technical Support team.